hey I'm Conan O'Brien welcome to serious
jibber-jabber you're with Judd Apatow
the producer director and screenwriter
some of the most successful comedies in
recent years including anchorman 40 year
old virgin knocked up bridesmaid
Superbad and Talladega Nights just to
name a few of 700 his latest film this
is 40 opens December 21st Judd thanks a
lot for being here
it's great to be here so much to talk
about I want to start i I'm a few years
older than you by old are you I'm 49
this I was born in 63 and but I know
that you were born a couple of years
later for me comedy was not an option
when I was a kid it it didn't no one in
my family was in show business I'm
living in Boston and then I saw it as
this great escape but I never really
thought it could happen how did it all
happen for you was it a similar
experience you know I had something that
made me think things were possible which
was my grandfather was a Skye Bobby shad
who produced jazz and so he was a legend
in the family he produced the first
Janis Joplin record and he produced
Dinah Washington and and Dizzy Gillespie
and Charlie Parker and he was this guy
from the Bronx who loved jazz just you
know normal kid from no money Depression
era kid who somehow saved up enough
money to go recorded you know a jazz
group and they might press some records
and sell it and slowly he started his
own label and worked for labels and was
this great kind of self-made man and
somewhere in my head I must have thought
oh you can do that in comedy if you're
just a lunatic and you work hard and you
obsess over it you can get in so I
always thought I could get in I just
knew it would take a crazy amount of
work did you when did you get a sense
that you had comedy abilities like how
how how young were you when you realized
okay this is a superpower that I have I
I liked comedy much more than I was
I just was obsessed with Bill Cosby
first my dad loved Cosby so
wonderfulness the chicken heart monster
all of that and I'd listen to George
Carlin and then you know Saturday Night
Live hit so started out live hit when I
was 8 so maybe but on the second or
third season I was really trying hard to
stay up late and not fall asleep and
guys watch SNL and but I don't think I
was that funny I was like a little kid I
had to make jokes and and the classic
you know making fun of yourself because
you're picked last in gym class and yeah
I would know about that
yeah relate yeah which was an awful
thing it really did ruin your whole life
because Jim was every day and at lunch
everyone would play sports every day so
there were two times every day where you
were publicly humiliated as being worse
than half the girls in your grade and
and I always thought well I'm in right
field the ball never gets to me so I
never have an opportunity to show them
that I deserve to be anywhere else
and I always felt like I've been this
like cycle of failure yes like a cop can
ask nightmare they wouldn't lever
there's no lefties hitting anything a
red field well so you you you know it's
funny because now comedy is ubiquitous
it's everywhere it's just like there's a
lot more comedy than there was when we
were kids
yeah way way more and no one liked
comedy there weren't like people I could
share it with I was obsessed with it I
didn't have like my nerd friend and we
talked about Steve Martin together right
I was completely alone
there was no Conan like at school and so
when I went to California went to USC to
film school I started doing stand-up but
and then I met you know all these people
like you'd be Dana Gould and you could
talk for 10 hours about Monty Python
right it took until I was 18 19 20 years
old to find those people it was like
being the B girl in the Blind Melon
video right and then suddenly like oh
look at all of these like great nerds
who know everything that I know about
Michael Keaton's stand-up career okay
there's a funny thing that happened the
other day I'm watching television Dick
Van Dyke
an old Dick Van Dyke shows on and it's
from I think was from 1962 and Rob Petry
and and his wife are Merritt Allen were
invited to a party
and he's really nervous because it's a
party of intellectuals and important
people and he says I'm I'm just the head
writer for the Alan Brady show and he's
very self-conscious and thinks he's
gonna be judged he goes to the party and
no one cares about him and I thought
that wouldn't happen today that's such
an marker of the time in when we were
kids
in the late 60s or through the 60s and
probably even into early into the 70s
I don't think comedy was a legitimate
option you don't I mean my parents are
professionals it wasn't a legitimate
option and then overnight there all
these like today there are kids at brown
and Yale whose and their parents their
biggest dream for them would be to be
you when that might be a nightmare
scenario twenty years ago it became like
as respectable as stockbroker Jerry yeah
because they we've seen that that's
where all the Harvard guys go they go to
the Simpsons and right right for all of
these shows yeah it didn't - it's our
fault I think a funny thing I wrote a
Simpsons episode exactly 22 years ago oh
and I would have been there then well I
know I think this pre day to you is I
wrote a during the firt what year was
the first season of Simpsons 8989
anything I wrote after 6:00 aired I
wrote my spec Simpsons and I was talking
about the story that that I wrote which
was about Homer taking the fans of
hypnotism show and being put under to
think he was ten and the hypnotist has a
heart attack and for the rest of show
him and Bart are best friends right and
then they go on the run because Homer
doesn't want to be woken up and have to
have responsibilities he loves being a
kid right and then I realized everything
I've done for my whole career is
basically that story you just said and I
told that story publicly for the first
time and then I got a call from The
Simpsons that said we're gonna shoot
that episode next year and not pay you
pay you know $2,200 so I can retire
that's all that was the first thing I
ever see again a Simpsons episode I'm
gonna but so yes it is a respectable job
and I mean it is almost like I guess
it's like being a singer song writer and
artist of
some sort it's a big part of the culture
comedy yes and a respectable part with
the daily show and things that affect
its politics become legitimate I think
and obviously there's a lot of shows
that came along in the 70s and 80s that
made it legitimate I was curious what
the movies are there it wasn't just the
movies there's a couple of events that
changed everything for me I really do
think Steve Martin was was I know for
you and was for me too Steve Martin
obviously very respected today I don't
know I can't explain to young people
sometimes who like him but I can't
explain to him what an atomic explosion
that was when he showed up how nobody
had been quite that funny before that's
how I felt I felt like things were funny
everything was and then Steve Martin
came along and it it almost took the air
out of the room it was so powerful did
you have that experience too I I mean I
must have talked in his accent for years
I mean I don't know how obnoxious I
could have been talking like him right
for years and and so he hit 78 79 is
like when it started happening on where
there would be these Saturday Night Live
episodes where every single sketch was
unbelievable it wasn't like a weekly a
canned half-hour being taught where
you're gathered around the TV it's a
different time today we would all be
watching it on the internet three months
later three months later you we sound
like 100 year old men but you're
gathered around your television and
you're watching him do King Tut
well you had no sense that any episode
of Saturday Night Live would ever be on
again so because you didn't know which
shows they would rerun or when there was
you know in that time no way to record
it right I used to record it with an
audio cassette recorder to listen to it
again so when you watched it it was you
know it was slipping through your
fingers as it as it was happening and I
guess because he was the first guy to
completely mock every tradition of
stand-up doesn't make fun of the whole
approach to it just made you laugh so I
because you've been conditioned to watch
all these other guys for so long and
then he's just
locking the whole thing I mean my the
steady diet when I was a kid with these
Bob Hope specials and only later on did
I go back and watch the Bob Hope movies
which are fantastic he's he's brilliant
he's amazing but you'd see these
specials where he's wearing the
conservative blue blazer joke joke joke
joke joke and then this guy comes along
and it did feel like overnight
everything changed they made the best
movie ever
then the jerk comes out yeah and your
mind is blown that he somehow took that
act and made the funniest movie ever the
first thing I ever did when I moved to
California and started getting some
writing jobs was try to find a way to
reach his agent to write the sequel to
the jerk yeah which he was never
interested in doing but that was my
dream what if there was another the jerk
but and then and then I mean you know
for me man with two brains I mean it
kept going for like many years with him
hitting that comedy that hard yes I mean
cruel shoes would he had the book and
while he's writing a book and it's kind
of short stories and and that you know
it seemed the only person before who had
because I had been a big fan of Woody
Allen's prose I loved his short stories
I loved the way he wrote and and and and
thought that was the funniest writing I
had read and then I loved that Steve
Martin came along in that tradition and
said no this is cool you can write him
look and it's funny because I just I
just took a photograph with him for
Vanity Fair I you know when I was a kid
I was driving past his house with my
grandma because we knew where he lived
and so any time we went anywhere no
matter what direction we had to drive
past Steve Martin's house and one day
Steve Martin is just in front of his
house so I jumped out of the car and I
asked him for his autograph and he said
I'm sorry don't sign autographs at my
house which is a very you know if
someone came to my house I'd be calling
armed people right to deal with it so
but at the time I didn't know you don't
walk up to people at their homes and he
said no I don't sign autographs my house
I said well why don't you sign it in the
street which was pretty good for 12 yeah
for 12 not a bad joke he said no I
really I can't cuz then people are gonna
come all the time he was very polite I
went home in a rage I was like I why I
was so mad and I wrote this letter to
him you know dear Steve drew the
funniest man in the world when you treat
your fans like crap and
I didn't buy all your records and go to
all your movies you wouldn't live in
that house and if you don't send me an
apology I'm gonna send your address to
homes of the stars and you're gonna have
tour buses passing by 24 hours a day
this is crazy right and then I put it in
his mailbox like I know where you live
so six months later I got a package I
open it up it's cruel shoes and inside
and this is 1980 so this is 32 years ago
it says to Judd I'm sorry I didn't
realize I was speaking to the underlined
Judd Apatow you know it's sad now that
inscription is not funny
you know someone sees it now it's just
like do you really mean your fame has
ruined that inscription
well the anecdote is like my only good
anecdote and I tell it all the time I
always feel bad he actually told that
anecdote he co-opted the anecdote and
told it on a talk show so we took a
picture mocking that story for Vanity
Fair a couple of weeks ago which was
just one of the highlights of my life
now I want to talk a little bit about
your process you you you use improv and
you use great improvisational actors
I've always had a problem with improv I
started an improv and and back in 1985
when I came out to LA that's the first
thing I wanted to do when I would do it
at night I'd do my writing gig and then
I'd go to improv classes I would do
shows and I always thought this is great
but you've got to use it very carefully
because it can be abused you're someone
who uses improvisation with great
control I think other people see what
you're doing and think oh right improv
that's how you do it and then things
meander all over the place what's your
technique on the set to make sure that
improv is calibrated correctly and that
people just don't go on for six hours
babbling yeah well I think some of it
has been misunderstood there certainly
seems where we get there and we know
this scene doesn't work what are we
thinking okay what am I gonna do most
days it's really not improv it's
rewriting on its feet yes you know we
start doing the scene and then I and
then I just
just take out a pad or so you know a lot
of times I'll have you know co-producer
who's a writer like Paul Appel from
Saturday Night Live and we just try to
beat the jokes you know we're not
changing the scene at all like the basic
direction of the scene is exactly the
same and then while we're watching we do
a process where after a bunch of takes
where we really work on performance I
just interrupt and yell out alternate
lines and it almost becomes any problem
between me and the actors and it's
something that you know Ben Stiller does
and Adam McKay does it's a menudo Will
Ferrell's at the anchor desk Adam McKay
will just keep giving him you know
bizarre line I'll say you in the ovaries
exactly and that comes from just a
stream of consciousness that can only
happen because you're watching the scene
there are scenes where we do let it go
that definitely happens you know the
whole thing in the the 40 old virgin
there was a couple of scenes with Steve
where we knew okay we're gonna wax Steve
we don't really need to script this I
just said Steve I would just like you to
curse at the woman doing it and then
apologize and then we talked about some
curses but I didn't know in what order
and I just waxed them and then you know
then I would you know switch to a
close-up and give him some alternate
jokes to get specific right the you know
how I know you're gay was something that
just kind of came out of a long Babli
you know chat while they were doing
video games and then we said oh this is
funny and we took a 45 minute break and
wrote 50 of them my favorite ones are
the ones that are emotional an emotional
moment that comes up for instance in the
new movie there's a moment when Leslie's
talking to my daughter iris so iris is 8
when we shot this and they're in bed and
she just starts talking iris about you
know do you want to have kids and iris
says I only want to have one because you
have two one fights with the other and
Leslie says do you does it bother you
when people fight she's like no I don't
want anybody to fight and that's just an
improv powerful moment though it makes
you very sad it may be sad yeah it's
terrible
that's because you know you think you
know she doesn't like when she fights
with her sister she doesn't like you
know if she ever sees
it's in our house hey but she also knows
the movie like she's a good actress
she's tracking the story even as an
eight-year-olds she knows she's in bed
post fight and so you know sometimes I
think weird and magical happens that you
can't get that rhythm unless you open it
up for the actors now I do not I don't
think I could work with anyone that I'm
related to I don't know I I love my
family I'm really close to them but I
haven't worked with them is it in some
ways I would imagine would be easier
that you work with your wife and
children in other ways I would think
maybe it's more difficult it's reckless
it definitely feels you know when it's
done I always think that was crazy what
was I thinking that really could have
gone wrong yeah because when we're doing
it I just think if this movie's bad it's
just a worldwide humiliation for my my
wife we've all gone down with yeah I
mean this really would be terrible
because people were inclined to not like
you for doing it I mean I think that
people have issues with people like
working with family for some reason but
you know my wife is just such an
incredible actress and she does
something that I just haven't seen
anyone do which is she can play the
deepest emotional life of a person and
and stuff that's sad and intense and
then she also can do funny at the exact
same time so you can be you know getting
jokes in the in a moment that's hard
drama yeah in addition to playing light
comedy and I just haven't seen anybody
who can go to that emotional level
there's a scene in knocked up which
she's mad at Paul Rudd because she's had
a website looking to find out where all
the child molesters are who live in
their neighborhood and Paul won't take
it seriously and keeps making jokes like
oh so we won't trick-or-treat at their
house and and if you see her getting
madder and madder so finally she just
talks about wanting to rip his face off
and he would kill in a movie theater but
if you watch it alone there's nothing in
her face that says I'm going for a laugh
right and that's a kind of laugh I love
like oh this is hard reality but yet it
still allows for
some you know laughs release and then my
kids are strangely funny and they're
bored of being on set so they're not
scared that cameras are around they're
very unselfconscious it's very most kids
are self-consciousness actors and
obviously there's something very good
there they just seem very much
themselves well they get sucked into
what their real problems are with each
other right like they're they're so
annoyed with each other
that they're not distracted by the fact
that they're shooting a movie and it
needs to go well they're more concerned
about whatever argument I'm trying to
make them have on camera so if I say
okay Maude tell her that she can't watch
lost she's she's too young
what wants her to not watch lost she's
mad she's like I'm you know I'm 14 years
old I'm allowed to watch lost you're
eight you have to wait six years and if
you see it before six years I got
screwed and so she's mad and then iris
really doesn't get why she can't watch
lost in her head I can handle any TV
show I can handle any violence any
Content and then they just get sucked in
and they just forget and well they're
tapping into something real yeah Maude
is pissed that there's a scene where
Maude they talk about taking away the
Wi-Fi in the house and Maude she knows
it's funny and she's performing but
she's mad because we've done that to her
at times and she's using it yeah so it's
kind of weird that they know how to do
it it's like giving them a skill I don't
know where else they'll use it because
most people don't shoot this way and
it's not like we're trying to make them
actors we're not I just wanted this
movie to work the only danger I would
think is them seeing the movie and
you've got family members who say
where's that take exactly the moment
where I did this was brilliant yeah and
yeah and what's going on and you're
stuck in a car ride with him for six
hours you've kind of excited two
terrible moments of oh no I don't want
my kids to turn into weird child
celebrities one was when iris was 8 I
had put her in several movies and cut
her out every time and she's turned to
me at 8 and said daddy I am so tired of
getting thrown into
the DVD extras I thought this is a bad
sign and the other one was Maude was not
happy to be on the same card for her
credit with iris why is everything
together I'm not a partner with her
that's fantastic so you they're already
developing exact those same resentments
you have said you do not consider
yourself smart I don't understand what I
don't understand that that statement
well I I feel like I'm emotionally in
tune and observant and some of my
neuroses are helpful for for comedy but
I don't have a lot of brain power my
memory is not very good and kind of you
know complex ideas don't stick but I do
understand people's emotional life which
it might be the highest form of
intelligence really I got it I don't
know it does I mean I'm still you know
neurotic as hell and surprised that you
know how how it shows itself changes as
I get older but it's probably the same
amount of neuroses I mean I don't know
how you are but you know when I like go
to school to pick up my kids the second
I hit that hallway I'm gonna hate the
grave again I'm embarrassed I feel like
a nerd I feel like nobody likes me I you
know it's just it becomes like your
imprint and I become the coolest kid in
school do you look at me I'm 6 4 I'm in
2nd grade I have a TV show but no I know
you you know obviously it's been said
many times to be funny you need to be in
touch with some kind of insecurity and
I've many times thought I do not know
how a handsome well-adjusted person who
girls liked when they were in the third
grade who were natural athletes could
ever be funny
why isn't Matt Damon funny yeah what's
Clooney funny where does it come from
it bad fun I'm going on record
they're funny they're they're you know
they're leading actor funny exactly okay
and I'll take this on me by the way no
I've they are and it's unfair because I
feel that I've come by this is what I
had that's how it felt to me I went
through a checklist of what are my
options and then I got to okay
at least I seemed to be able to make my
friends laugh and then I put all my
money on 27 red you know everything and
when someone else comes along who who is
pretty funny and they're also a great
athlete and they seem like they're they
had a great time for me if they enjoyed
school I hated school and I was a kid
just hated it and when I hear about kids
that love to go into school they love
school they got laid a lot and they're
funny yeah good at sports
yeah those people know there's two or
there's something to be seven in the
world but they need to die
it was funny Obama Obama funny I think
it's really talk about this because is
it is he really funny or is he learned
the rhythm has he learned the rhythm
because he needed to and he's very smart
guy I have not been able to get a handle
on how naturally funny Obama is I don't
think we've had very many naturally
funny presidents I actually think often
it's a liability I think John F Kennedy
was maybe our last
really funny president did they get a
good sense of irony I don't know he's
Obama funny I saw a town hall meeting he
was doing when he was running for
president the first time and he was so
funny and also a little cutting with the
crowd and and and a sophisticated sense
of humor that I realized that they're
holding him back and that if he showed
people how funny he is people would
dislike him that it was you know maybe
there's almost something you know
condescending and being that funny with
the with common people but I thought oh
this is not a side that they want to
show it's funny cuz I you say that
because I've been friends for many years
with Al Franken and then he becomes a
senator and I can see he works really
hard and never be funny he works so hard
worked so hard at not saying the funny
idea that comes into his head because in
the world we live in now it has to be
knock us when you read it on the printed
page now you've been in writers rooms
all your life and so if I I say a
thousand things a day and so do all my
writers that if it was read at a trial
you could not defend it they would say
did you say this mr. O'Brien yes I did
say that about that horrible thing that
happened in history defend it I can't
yeah I do take my kids all day long I
think there's nothing funnier than
inappropriate humor to children I do F
Nick humor right I do terrible voices
that would end my career
right it makes me laugh so hard and then
makes them laugh so are they they repeat
it they don't repeat it we have a real
rule like this is jokes for the house
jokes for the house don't thank you
that's cool you could get expelled for
it but it doesn't but you know
inappropriateness is always funny yes
yes
my favorite thing is what would be the
worst thing I could do I spent hours and
hours and hours with my writers and with
my staff acting out the worst thing I
could ever do and they'll be crying
they'll be laughing so hard and then of
course I can't even do it on this on the
show on the TV show even if it's an edgy
show because it's too much that's the
whole career ender exactly interview is
the potential career ender right because
anything can just get spread so it
doesn't matter you I could be doing an
interview with some local video site in
Australia and I say the wrong thing and
it's it's done
and then we all turn our backs on you
which we would instantly that's how it
works
I get that let's talk about the talent
you have found Seth Rogen Jonah Hill
Jason Segel James Franco Lena Dunham how
are you finding these people in an era I
sometimes think it's only gotten harder
to find the really great people because
everybody's everywhere they're all on
YouTube sites and in a way the
technology has made it harder to focus
how do you find these people how do you
know that they're that good I mean when
you first met Jonah Hill did you think
some day this guy is gonna be an
oscar-nominated actor well Jonah Hill is
a finding starting cuz we were looking
for someone to do one line in the 40 old
virgin he was the person that went into
the eBay store and didn't understand the
concept of a store that sold you stuff
on eBay
and he just
laughs we could tell he was funny and on
the day we had a lot of free time so we
forced him to improvise for 40 minutes
with Catherine Keener purely to make him
nervous and he just made us laughing and
then some of that made its way into the
movie so then you just go other guy's
funny and then when I was doing knocked
up he had become friends and everybody I
thought I'm just gonna hire ol upsets
actual friends we're gonna use their
real names and use this real dynamic and
then in the middle of that shoot we were
trying to cast super bad one day we went
hold why don't we just use Jonah yeah
he's perfect so it kind of happens like
that I think it's the same as you know
with your show where at some point
you're looking for like a funny woman
and you're like hey why don't we throw
Amy pohler in this sketch she's funny
yeah and and that's kind of the same
like with the movie it's the same as
deciding you know let's put you know
just any of the people that you've
thrown into like sketches it's the same
for a movie you just go what's with that
James Franco guy he seems kind of
interesting and and that's kind of all
the research it's kind of like being a
fan of comedy where you see comedians
all day long but everyone saw you go oh
that guy's crazy funny that Hannibal
Buress oh my god yeah that's a whole
nother thing and you notice that in an
audition someone just pops and you go
Jason Segel that kid is crazy for
there's a lot going on there emotionally
he's interesting he's vulnerable and you
know we've gotten lucky with how many of
them turned out to be really good for me
there's such a this points been made by
other people but I don't think it's been
made enough comedy and music mm-hmm I
know that you're interested in music I
love music I always think there's a it's
the same idea
musicians find each other just because
they hear someone playing and they know
that they can fall in with them and play
with them and comedy is the exact same
thing where you know I started with the
late night show in 93 and I just knew
that I have to do this with Robert
Smigel
yeah and that's just the thing I know
first and shortly after that I found
Andy Richter we didn't even know what we
were going to do with him I met him in a
restaurant and I thought he's just we
need him and it's like Robin Hood and
his Merry Men and then Louie Louie CK
was one of our first writers and we just
he
he's just really funny now it took a
long time for technology I think in the
world to catch up to Louie but he was
this funny in 1993 but you find all
these people and then it just you know
there's a list right of all these people
and really it's just your taste it just
comes down to your taste and what do you
personally connect to someone gave me a
tiny furniture lena Dunham's movie yeah
and I put it in I didn't know she wrote
it I didn't know she was the actress in
it I didn't know the name Lena Dunham
somebody just said this movie's
interesting and I would I watched it and
at the end I'm like so she wrote it she
directed she produced it that's her
sister and her mom playing her mom and
and it cost eight dollars eight dollars
a night and it just blew my mind and I
thought well I love this it's like
personal intimate comedy and she's using
her family I relate to everything she's
trying to do and so I just contact her I
go what do you what are you doing can I
help you with anything and then you know
she told me about about this girl's idea
she was beginning to think about and and
that and it's like that with each each
person and I you know I'm just like a
fan you know what I meet even when I
meet someone like Seth Rogen when he's
16 years old part of my mind is just a
fan going I'd like to watch that guy do
funny stuff yeah well I don't know what
it is and then as he revealed that he
was actually very thoughtful and had his
own ideas writer oh I'd love to see him
as the lead no one ever lets that guy be
the lead I want to see that guy in the
lead that'd be an interesting kind of
person to put in a movie and then he
just rocks it you know so that's that's
the fun part is to give people an
opportunity and then they just exceed
any expectation you had for what they
could do were you you were a fan of Jim
Carrey's mmm and then got to know him
yeah and of course everybody knows it
just that spectacular explosion Carrie
explosion which was a lot which was I
think similar to a lot of people for the
Steve Martin explosion when when he hit
there was a oh my god this guy is funny
on a different level
he's so physically reckless he's so
committed I was there's a you know I
edited this issue of Vanity Fair that
you wrote a hilarious piece or like it
really was hysterical and there's a
picture Jim Carrey and I had to ride the
caption for it and I said you know Jim
Carrey's the funniest man on earth we
could all debate number two all day long
but Jim Carrey is the funniest guy and
you know when I was doing stand-up I
would go to the improv in the valley it
was in the Hilton Hotel and David Spade
would be there it was like the the
conference room but great people like
Drake say they were there and Sandler
would come in and Jim Carrey started
coming in and I had seen him do
impressions on TV but he was you know he
that's what his act was he would do
Sammy be Sammy Davis jr. and Clint
Eastwood and James Dean and it was
remarkable because he could make his
face look like anybody which was super
weird right but but really ingenious but
he decided I'm not gonna do any
impressions I'm tossing everything out
I'm gonna write an axe I'm gonna go on
stage I'm gonna improvise and play and
every night Jim Carrey with crazy young
man energy would semi-improvised for 20
minutes and it was the best thing I had
ever seen it was so bizarre and funny
and he would kill and then he would bomb
so hard for five minutes and then he
would win them back and I called my
manager Jimmy Miller and I said this is
the funniest thing I'd ever seen and he
signed him and and I don't get
Commission I got nothing so I used to
open a collection for you later yeah but
I would open on the road for him so we
would go remember we went to the Atlanta
punchline yeah and he had just done like
half a season of it living collar so no
one really knew who he was and and he
was you know so physical and so funny
and then after the show we would be
talking and then suddenly like we're
talking and talking and then it's like
it's 7:00 in the morning and and we've
stayed up all night and she has so much
energy he's it's like nothing you've
ever seen he stole that way - yeah which
is he still has incredible energy and
there is a sweetness about him he is
very genuine about comedy and what's
right and what's good and people being
good to each other there's a there's an
energy that comes off of him that I
still find really inspirational I think
that's why people you know connect with
him
you know the the second night we were in
Atlanta I was like wow that was wild we
stayed up all night talking that was
incredible and an inspirational and
hilarious and then the next night it was
like 4:00 in the morning I'm like he's
gonna do it again yeah he's ready to
like go and and he's always been like
that that's been just a really fun thing
to be around it's seeing him Gettys
venture and the mask and eternal
sunshine and just just as a friend to
watch him take these crazy risks and
really succeed a lot I mean when we did
Cable Guy it really was a crazy thing to
do which is okay now I want to play this
demented person and I speak with a lisp
and it's kind of a parody of unlawful
entry and hand that rocks the darkness
to it yeah and he's like I'm not gonna
play the same guy in every movie he was
throwing down the gauntlet I'm gonna do
different things and that led to doing
The Truman Show and I love you Philip
Morris because he was like I'm gonna do
everything you know in this career I'm
not gonna just get stuck in one style of
humor I'll go back to that I like that
also but I also you know Cable Guy now
do you go back and watch it I'm at the
time so much was written about just what
it what his paycheck was it all got
distorted and I feel like it's one of
those movies that when I see it now
there's so much good stuff in there and
I think at the time it feels a lot to me
that it was a variety headline about
what he was getting paid twenty million
dollars the budget was 40 in wound up
costing 42 it grossed a hundred but at
the time was like how come it didn't
make two hundred and so people expected
it just be some cash cow and when I
watch it now I definitely watch anything
this movie is crazy weird and there's so
many bizarre things in it and when we
shot it we laughed so hard every day
like there was you know scenes where it
was just Lisp jokes but Jim would just
do it so funny there was a scene where
he's like listening to a tape like how
to fix your Lisp I got cut out and he
would just sit there for like minutes
you know before the scenes started going
salmon salmon and we would laugh so hard
and then when you know we put the movie
together and it was it was meant to be
thriller it got a little scarier as a
story yeah and it's had this great
afterlife and I really loved it but at
the time you kind of don't realize like
what is little scarier than we thought
maybe we intended right yeah I mean I
always thought this thing is like a
roller coaster ride I mean you know it's
silly but people got scared because in
the middle of it Jim beats up Owen
Wilson yes and you can't don't see it
coming that he gets physical and then it
was quite violent it she makes him suck
out the air blow in the bathroom yeah
yeah which Owen hated he hated that that
that was in the scene of him like
blowing the blow-dryer and I didn't know
he hated it so I gave him a photograph
of somebody pointed to a garbage can he
had torn it up but after that for the
rest of the movie I think people thought
like the Cable guy's gonna kill somebody
yeah and so it's hard to laugh at some
of the jokes it's a great second time
movie the second time you see it you
know okay Jim doesn't kill anybody we're
okay and you know Jack Black's in it and
the Bob and Andy and Jeanine from the
Ben Stiller show there's a lot of kind
of great you know actors that we loved
in it was airplane is his atom
completely I was airplane and
influential movie for you I wouldn't see
airplane when I was on vacation in
California visiting my grandmother in
Sherman Oaks the line was insanely long
and my main memory was John Davidson the
great talk-show hosts you know variety
show entertainer best hair ever
intelligent ass to care walking to the
front of the line and telling the
manager that he needed to be let in
because he was gonna get surrounded by
fans mmm
he used that to do the work worked the
best would be if it didn't work and the
long walk back I knew that movie in that
theater there's no there's three movies
that I remember is the funniest movies
I'd ever seen I've ever seen in the
theater one was a airplane okay Matt a
madhouse laughs like I've ever seen
right I went to see in you know for the
revival theater Young Frankenstein Young
Frankenstein pandemonium like I really
didn't expect it and I went with Stiller
on opening night
- to Santa Monica and watch something
about Mary yes and that was the us big
glasses I saw something about marrying a
test screening I don't know why I was
there but it was some kind of test
screening and I went and it was a kind
of and it was a real audience it was not
an industry crowd it was just real
people they lost their mind yeah I mean
the air turned into in the atmosphere
changed it was but airplane was a movie
that I remember at the time like there's
no real stars in this at the but it was
the first time I saw someone used the
deliver it as if it were deadly serious
actually that's not true the first time
I thought was the Batman series with
Adam West you know where it's just
you're saying something absurd but with
great great seriousness and and I guess
The Pink Panther movies had done that
too but airplane just and so many jokes
I watched it with my like my daughter's
10 now but I did watch it with her when
she was 8 and it's kind of dirty
there's like a there's there's a joke
where it's the voices when you pull up
to the airport saying you know the red
zone is for the lights and then they
start like fighting about whether or not
she's gonna get an abortion or how dirty
the movie got and there were so many
jokes that I thought oh they're the it
just to the blow-up pilots like blow
each other it's like there's a lot of a
Randy humor in it but it is it
completely holds up everything he holds
out yeah
and I I to me I think that must have
been a fun writers room when I see
things I think that would be a great
because I love the writers room I think
that's where some of the biggest laughs
I've had in my life have never been on
camera they've all been in the writers
good bad about that you know I really
don't I really don't I actually think
there's something kind of magical about
that there have been enough laughs on
the television shows and and enough
that's worked really well that I'm I
feel fine I just don't think you can
ever there's a purity to no one else is
gonna hear it this way I don't know if
you've ever been in a I mean had that
feeling in a room where something
happens someone gets going on a rig
and you know I'm never gonna capture
this by the time we get this in front of
the equipment it's gonna be gone yeah
well you were legend in the rooms where
I was in other comedy rooms and we would
hear how funny you were in the rooms and
like how come we don't have a guy be
enough
no I am when I was on The Simpsons I
thought I always was the Morey Amsterdam
of the writers room that's a stiff room
somewhat yeah it's a lot of thinkers I
mean I worked for the critic for Al Jean
and Mike Reiss now I don't know if
people know this but you know when you
work on an animated show especially how
they do it you come in at 10:00 and you
work till like 7:00 8:00 9:00 o'clock
sometimes later but these guys don't
budge I mean al Jean would fill up like
a cup with pretzels and maybe a couple
of M&Ms and he'd lay back and they go
okay can we beat this line and sometimes
an hour on one line and and everyone's
just thinking and thinking so hard in
between debates about Fermat's theorem
and just math thing my ways I was mad
because I need energy I need I need it
to be kinetic so you had all these best
writers I've ever worked with it's
George Meyer and John VD and Reese and
gene and Schwartz well Nene's not doing
any dances no they're all sitting there
and I was being look around if you like
you know we need it what could Marge say
at this moment and then 20 minutes would
go by and we're sitting on furniture
that you would throw out of your dorm
room and they don't think a break they
don't take a break and so I started
inventing any kind of crazy way to make
them laugh and then I became their
monkey and and then actually they would
say send you off to write your script
but they would always pull me back
pretty quickly because they just won in
the show and I would do anything and
that's when no one else would do that at
those shows yeah a lot of math majors
strangely it was yeah and and brilliant
guys but the writers room is not I was
I need a fun writers room I just do I
need it to be a show I need the writers
room to be a show and I've been kicked
out by my writers because I'm wasting
their time yeah do you remember when
there was that lawsuit where
one of the writers assistants at friends
of the show because of all the
inappropriate jokes I actually did the
first thing I've ever driver directed
was an episode of the Larry Sanders Show
which was about the Scott Thompson suing
the show because there's too many gay
jokes being made in the I us right and
that that's kind of a funny thing for
some of the sooo show for inappropriate
humor because there is unlimited
inappropriate humor in a room like god I
mean come 1:30 2:00 in the morning it
shows like Larry Sanders where you know
you would be there till 3:00 in the
morning of a fair amount
it gets crazy like what does those do
and the other thing is I always have
thought it's kind of like nuclear
fishing you need to create this heat
this level of heat to make something
funny happen and it needs to happen in a
contained lead box yeah it's 15 feet
thick yeah and that's what Jen and then
that generates the steam that comes
shooting out at high pressure and that
powers the lights when someone says like
the amount of heat that's how you know
it has to be inappropriate it has to be
wildly inappropriate and I think that's
it's also impossible to explain to
anybody because as you said if you read
a transcript of some of the things that
you and I have rift on in a room or
anybody that we know is ripped on in a
room it's indefensible and no one would
back you up I remember once when we were
making heavyweights in North Carolina I
doubt I was sober but maybe the Olympics
was on and I was just doing play-by-play
as the announcer for ice skating yeah
but maybe for two solid out noxious
inappropriate career-ending play-by-play
and those are the most fun moments is
the footage exists all right you know
there Paul Sims that Larry Sanders Show
did take some there there's some video
of so he can hold that over your head
we have I want to talk about this is 40
which I have to say when I watched the
movie I've moved to two and a half three
years ago from New York to LA and when I
first started watching this movie it was
very personal
me because I have a wife kids that are
approximately the age of your kids and I
live in this same area that you're
depicting literally the same area
literally the same area and that's drug
gets on a bicycle with Robert Smigel and
one of the first scenes and is riding on
San Vicente which I do and so I got very
uncomfortable because I thought I'm I
don't like this this is too close to me
but we have a clip here from from this
is 40 do you know which clip this is is
it the bathroom clip it's Plaza escaped
Pete has escaped into the bathroom he
likes his free time and he uses it in
the bathroom
let's take a look hey what are you doing
I got a bad
we're all downstairs waiting for you
you've been up here for a really long
time now oh I'm almost done I'll be done
in a second mm-hmm Charlotte just did
her first flip on the trampoline and she
landed on her feet she was really proud
of herself well that's great and you
missed it so do it again it's the fourth
time you've gone to the bathroom today
give me a break
why is your instinct to escape somebody
NSYNC to escape from you it is my
instinct to come into the bathroom when
I need to go to the bathroom how come I
don't smell anything it's cuz I shoved
an Altoid up my ass before I came in
here I mean let me see then what let me
see
no I'm not gonna let you see you're not
gonna let me see because you're not
taking a poop I've been flushing as I go
you're flushing as you go
who takes a half hour to go to the
bathroom John Goodman don't press ENTER
I'm not sure I want to make that move I
love that he immediately has John
Goodman at his disposal and he's
probably Corrales there's so many
options yeah John Goodman you've
completely emasculated Paul Rudd is in
this scene he is sitting on the toilet
having to defend whether or not he has
yes which is absolutely fantastic there
are no barriers the berries have broken
down I have to ask is this something
you're commenting on in your own life
have it's it's the total evaporation of
dignity between the husband and the wife
well I wanted to have scenes about the
lack of mystery in a relationship when
you've known someone for so long you've
just shown every orifice and every thing
that makes everything kind of gross and
not sexy anymore
yeah since I sat down and you know
there's that scene and there's another
scene where Paul asked her to look at
his anus because he thinks he might have
either hemorrhoid a worm or a tear and
he wasn't sure which wants her to check
it and wants her to check out because
they're partners and now my wife would
never walk in the bathroom but she's
definitely checking Twitter to see if
I'm posting so so that's kind of where
you know imagination comes in because
when we do these movies you know it's
basically a third is from life a third
is Bob survey
to the 3rd I'm just making up so Leslie
would never come in but in my
imagination that's the fight we would
have yeah and it's and Paul Rudd is so
good at mean what I love is the struggle
for him to defend himself while he's on
the toilet with an iPad that's the best
thing is that he is defending himself
and it's like you know your pants around
your ankles people on your yeah you lost
the fight the minute she walked in you
were done any fine if you videotaped
you'd see that I've lost right in fact
he's lost the second chances are because
he's on the iPad he doesn't move which I
love it just he goes like this as if
he's gonna hide it and then he kind of
decides he can't and hold it up but you
know that's the thing I like about that
teen is unless he opens the door she
knows she's gonna blast them she's she's
giving him a moment to just cop to it
she's just saying just tell me you're
bad and then I won't be mad at you right
and it's the defense that gets him in
trouble and that's a lesson in the
cover-up it's what we learned in
Watergate exactly the Nexen it said of
course everyone does this I make that
mistake every day it's always that I did
I you know years later they'll be
periods where there was a line that I
cut out of the movie there's a scene
between Robert Smigel and and Pete where
he turns to smegal he says is there a
chance I'm wrong about everything and so
I was like oh yeah definitely probably
definitely wrong about everything
the for me personally I when I come home
the end of the day I don't want to see
comedy yeah and it's a problem because
there's a lot of funny stuff out there
I'll come home and my wife wants to
watch modern family who's you know or
she wants to watch a comedy and what I
want to do a perfect example of a movie
I would want to watch after a day of
thinking of comedy and after for me
about 26 years of thinking about comedy
all the time is I want to go see
downfall the German movie about Hitler
in the bunker and I want to watch it I
want to go as far from what we do I want
to watch a dry documentary about Ken
Burns on the Brooklyn Bridge exactly I
don't want to see irony I don't
see a silliness I don't want to see
anybody riffing are you that way or can
you enjoy comedy when you're at the end
of a long day
well I was thinking when you said that
in the last year - I've had the the
first moments in my life where I thought
is comedy just a way of not being
truthful and a way of hiding
you know how I'm really feeling or
needing a protection when trying to get
certain feelings across and there are
moments where it's not just that I'm
sick of comedy I get moments where I'm
tired of all storytelling and all modern
entertainment yes because I'm just so in
the thick of trying to think of things
and write things and give notes and then
I just hate everything he's books I hate
books a magazines and I just want to
shut my brain off but then a good
episode of Mad Men will come on yeah and
then Ivan back in and you back in yeah I
have the same thought I have the
thoughts sometimes and I don't like the
possible answer which is do people need
more entertainment from me I have that
thought like I've done a couple of
thousand of these people kind of have
seen what I can do and I'll get this
very grim thought where I think there
may not I don't want to be doing this if
it's not needed you want to be needed
and if you're not needed I want to
become a welder I will actually want to
learn yeah it's the cobbler like the
Louis I want to join Daniel day-lewis
and learn to cobble shoes how long would
it take for you to get bored of you yeah
if you were watching you yeah I think
it's different talk shows because people
have runs with talk shows like won't
they be like years where like you watch
a certain talk show and you kind of get
into it and then you kind of give it a
break for like a year and then some of
you find yourself like just one episode
pulls you back in to a point of view
again it's funny it's like you're a
little--you're I've George Mayer who I
referenced earlier one of I think one of
the great television writers of all time
I get very down when I have a bad day or
a day where I don't think I did a good
show I go into a very dark place and he
talked to me about it once and he said
you're laying little pieces of mosaic
tile
and you can't see the whole mosaic
because it's made of thousands and
thousands of pieces so some days you're
writing avert you're laying on a very
brightly colored piece and you feel
great and other days it's like the faint
the light blue piece which is the
background for the thing but he said
it's all makes something when you're
done and I thought that was the most
beautiful rationale for just keep going
this is my point about me not being
smart I couldn't have thought of that oh
I couldn't I've given that to George
Walker but Ron Howard say that to me
early in my career where he he said he
always imagines that movies like a
pieces like a painting you know in a
gallery and he said you know I try not
to think about each one too much in
contacts in context of its importance in
my career I think about being at the end
of my career walking through that
hallway you know being proud of all of
these things that I've made right which
I thought was a great way to it's the
same it's the same idea which is you the
only way you can survive doing this
because I think comedies too hard I
really do I think it's too hard to hang
your I hang my self-esteem on each
moment of it sometimes and I think I you
can't do that but you can you could be
too unhappy for too long but you you do
it see when I did stand them I always
knew I wasn't as good as everybody else
but I also had like a insecurity thing
which was there's a part of my brain
that was always saying God cares what
you're saying why are you up there
babbling and I'll get that even now if I
you know I I did a speech I got an award
at this Hollywood Film Awards and and so
throughout the night I was bored and I
said you know as a joke I'm gonna make
notes on this entire show as if I'm the
producer and I'm giving notes at the end
of the night about how it went right
music you came in too early you know so
and the just vicious jokes about
everything and then when I got up I read
I just read it and it was maybe the
biggest laughs I've ever gotten in my
entire career the second I get home I am
so ashamed of myself I'm embarrassed I
feel like it's arrogant and and then I
don't sleep and there was not one
bad thing said to me people just thought
oh that was fantastic I've never seen
you funnier and I'm embarrassed at the
part of me that wants that so badly and
that that's part of why I became a
writer and so I'm still doing it I just
somehow found a way to kind of hide
behind the camera so here's the $64,000
question under now I believe there's a
neediness I have an incredible neediness
you have a neediness we want to make
people laugh it's more important to me
almost than breathing that's not healthy
always do we fix that if you had a
chance to fix it and you could be
happier do you fix it it's an eternal
question that never resolves itself I
get therapy I've had people tell me oh
don't get therapy because you're crazy
but you need to be crazy we need the
eggs no I've had it's it's just it's a
question that's out there you know
that's always out there if you're if you
live and die by comedy and it's a it's
why we make funny people having I spent
two years thinking about that yeah when
I was making funny people that I'm
saying there I just the you know the
whole movie was just me pondering what
is the point of this is wrong with me
that I need this so badly and is this
what you know what's wrong with all of
us because I have that just what you're
saying I feel that from everybody in our
community that some of us are doing it
for very healthy reasons and we're
sharing our ideas and there's kind of a
beautiful aspect to it but demented love
me please I'm hanging on every joke
aspect to it at the same time so for me
it was like Seth Rogen was a young
version of me so yeah is there a way for
me not to become this ass and then
there's like this antler which is kind
of like the part of me that's like am i
turning into an ass like buy into this
too much am I wasting my time where I
should be connecting with people more
and not being this kind of
people-pleasing machine I have to say
about funny people when I saw that movie
I walked out nice I thought it is so
hard to cap
sure how Comedy Works and I thought
funny people came closer than any movie
I could think of and I was referencing
things like punch line which is you
looked at it and remembered I know this
isn't what it's like to be stand-ups
don't have lockers no there was things
like that and there are TV shows like
studio 60 which had a lot of different
things in it that I really liked but it
was so serious about how Comedy Works is
we're and yeah and also just the my god
this is the most brilliant thing I've
ever like no that's not how we talk
that's not how it works
and I times think it's impossible to
depict really how it works but I thought
funny people got it got in there you
know it's like because you guys know an
atom knows and and and everybody felt
pretty truthful about how it's a messy
process an atom is just comfortable you
know revealing a certain side of himself
I mean it's really a brilliant
performance and and he was very
courageous to to go into a lot of those
spaces I mean I was really proud of just
you know his approach to the whole
project because you know when you're
gonna go work with a friend you're like
I hope he doesn't you know argue with me
about everything I wonder what its gonna
be like directing him and he was he
couldn't have been greater I mean he was
just so easy and then gave so much to it
that for me a lot of that experience was
just realizing how great a guy he was
and how creative he was and wanting
people to you know to see that as well
he's also a very he's a really good
actor and when I first met him on Stern
that live just you know before he'd even
become famous I was talking to him and
he told me that his idol was James Caan
and I thought I always thought at the
time I thought really like this young
super goofy and I can I've been able to
see it ever since then he has a Adam has
an intensity and he has like a spiritual
weight about him and you can see it and
punch-drunk love you can see it in in in
funny people like he has he had he is a
terrific actor he can be very truthful
that way and I think there a lot of
people that get to
tract it and think that he's the goofy
guy and one of his people Wow yeah I
mean after we made funny people you know
he was like you know people think when I
do a you know a different kind of movie
like oh now he's doing this different
kind of movie he should do more of these
and he's like I don't want to do more of
these I like doing one everyone's well
but you know I like to do I could really
figure out how to make people laugh
they're freaking asses off
yeah and that's but yet when you're
collaborating with him on something you
know that cut digs into pain and these
other ideas there's nobody better than
him
so I mean again like Jim Carrey you know
these guys have these careers where you
know Adam can you know make the wedding
singer and and make Big Daddy and all
these hilarious movies and then you see
punch-drunk love and then and then they
go back and Jim's like that too like I
was so happy to hear that Jim Carrey is
gonna do dumb in number Dumb and Dumber
to ya you know but I've also was blown
away by Philip Morris oh I like that
there's so many guys who have had both
careers you know any career in a comedy
career this brings up a really an area
that I have to get you to talk about
which is there seems to be a I'll be
silly and make the money but then I will
do be serious because I want to get the
Oscar yeah how can we get people beyond
that they need their if they're going to
reward comedy it has to be socially
important whereas to me one of my
favorite quotes is when Groucho did duck
soup a very urbane reviewer said to him
I yes so he watched duck soup instead so
this is your commentary on fascism the
rise of fascism in Europe and its need
to be stopped and and Groucho just
looked at him and said we're for Jews
trying to get a laugh that's who we are
that there seems to be it's been proven
over time that to get your award you
can't be too silly you can't be too
funny it's got to be nuanced
that people want that do you do you
think that that can ever change the
Academy Awards can ever just have a an
Oscar category for relief money movies
you know I wish that they would if it's
not you know you know part of it but I
know bridesmaids was nominated for two
awards last year and I that was a
encouraging sign I think that people
just intrinsically think something
dramatic and painful with accents is
harder to do than just an incredibly
well-crafted comedy like the wedding
singer yeah and it's just not true I
mean if I didn't have to have jokes I
could I could you know go to sleep in
much earlier I mean we're up late at
night on the joke part yeah and and
things can be just as complex in a
comedy as you know I don't know a Seth
Rogen is really funny on the subject of
why like people like you know world war
ii or holocaust dramas and think they
deserve awards and have no respect at
all for for comedies it means that i
forgot how he said it but he's like you
think it's hard to make people cry in a
holocaust movie like that's hard Animal
House might be a perfect movie but you'd
never give it an award I don't know that
you don't I mean it's never gonna be
where people are watching that tonight
than Gandhi yes no people don't Gandhi
in the afterlife is watching it right
now and saying my life was wasted this
is better than anything I did but I mean
I I do think a perfect comedy is next to
impossible to achieve and we don't
respect them as much as we should
yeah we like them we go see them hmm
what do we do we have our own awards a
Comedy Awards we'll hold it here in this
all-black room that we stole from
Charlie Rose everything when I lived
with Adam Sandler by the way everything
that we bought when we had to buy
furniture we put all our furniture in
one day for $980 for the entire
department and everything was this kind
of like black glass yeah this was we had
a table that we when we had this idea to
do this show for the first episode I
said it should be kind of Charlie Rose
ish and someone must have happened you a
million times where you say something
lightly and then a million people run
out and say this is what Judd wants
I came in to take the first show and it
was an exact duplicate of Charlie Rose's
me to a legally frightening degree and I
said no no no no that's the Jew said no
I just said Charlie Rose ish meaning
let's get rid of the audience let's have
it be black and I changed the table once
like for a week and and went with
something more like this and it just
destroyed the show the show to say I'm
unwatchable he became yeah and he went
insane for a while we have a question
here I'm gonna use this futuristic
tablet from 30 years in the future and
it goes like this
Nestle ahan from Facebook any favorite
actress yes Nestle ahan he's your old
friend any favorite actors you'd love to
work with other than the ones you
already have
who's out there that you'd love to work
with that's a good question you know
Zach Galifianakis makes me laugh he's
writing really hard like you know I'm
dead inside like you and so I'll like
know everyone so out something just
throws you like I'd be like I you know
Adam and Kate asked me to watch the
campaign when they were it was early
cuts yeah
and I didn't think much about enjoying
it I just thought okay I gotta watch
this and we give him some notes and it's
early and they're at it and I guess I
gotta do it tonight I'm kind of tired uh
and I put it on at 10:00 o'clock at
night and I it just surprised me that I
just started laughing my ass off and
just forgot completely about the task of
being helpful and and Zach really made
me make me laugh he was his little dog
walking through the town at the
beginning of the movie with his little
dog and he's a really funny character I
mean there's so many people I like I'm
just afraid you know I really need to be
able to write something that's worthy of
them so and there's people that I adore
it's just like anything of a story that
intersects with them so obviously I love
the people I grew up with like Steve
Martin and and and and Bill Murray and
people like that I mean there's just a
lot of like young hilarious people I
gave me Poehler that you just think oh
man she's so funny and it would be great
to try to fully max out what that is
because that's what happened when we did
bridesmaids is like how funny can we
make this how how how can we make this
like really emotional and really funny
and and push you know Kristin and Auntie
level of the writer to max this out and
and that that's the most fun part for me
would you be too intimidated to direct
Steve Martin and that you make a movie
with him in that situation he's imitated
in the writing I'm not intimidated once
like we get there if I like this scene
you know when I was working with Albert
Brooks and you know I couldn't look up
to anybody more than him yeah if if I've
talked to him about the scene by the
time we get to the set I kind of feel
like okay I don't know what I'm doing
but alone in a room going can I write a
scene that's funny enough for Albert
Brooks you know that's where you have
been meltdown I when I first came out
here to LA from New York after the
late-night show someone had a party and
I went to it and Albert Brooks walked up
and started talking to me I'd never met
him before I talked him for a while he
made me really laugh and left the party
got on my cell phone and started calling
everybody I I know and you think you get
to certain points you think can I meet
anybody any more than I think I've met
everybody and I've certainly I don't
want to get jaded and I was so thrilled
to just be in the same space as Albert
Brooks first time I met him it was in
the early 90s I went out to dinner with
him and Garry Shandling and I was so
excited that afterwards I wrote down
everything he said and there were a
couple of jokes that really made me
laugh one was he said I I forgot what
movie maybe were talking about defending
your life but he said yeah Tom Tom Hanks
said to me he said I saw your movie you
it was really smart really intelligent
and I thought why is he surprised that
it's intelligent he's the guy who did
the the show where he wore the dress not
me terrible half has the pressure my
tried to come I was if you're watching
this interview this long yeah you gotta
kick it up enough there's no one left at
this point but when I was talking to him
he did a really funny thing heat there
was another guy there who knew him it's
just three of us chatting and Albert
Brooks told some story that was said
something told some quick story that was
really funny and I don't remember that
and I laughed and his friend who was
standing next to him said
I guess he had to be there and Albert
and and our pup slipped in the way no
you you don't have to be there he killed
with Conan was fine
he was fought he left there's no other
place you need to be and in that Albert
Brooks way he just kept hammering his
friend there was there was no reason for
that comment and I thought I'm in an
Albert Brooks movie yeah oh it's the
best but he gets going it's the best I
also remember him talk about the
Menendez trial say you don't kill the
parents and then buy a Rolex sensible
purchases this is 40 yes is coming out
December 21st December 21st
go and see that film heavy weights is
coming out on DVD
look at that finally heavy weights on
DVD and and there's a great soundtrack
to this is 40 with music by Lindsey
Buckingham and Fiona Apple and Wilco and
John Bryan and good marker tracks I like
that part of it
that must be I get the impression you
just listen to music constantly yeah I
love it I love that I there's any way
for me to touch the music aspect of it
the fact that I can force people I
worship to write a song is the best
thing that's ever happened you're
sadistic cruel dictator gone mad hi Judd
hi this was if it was one-tenth as fun
for you as it was for me then we've done
something this was really cool Judd
thanks a lot thank you sir yeah